we're talking about if the man or we
always talk about if the man doesn't
want the kid and the woman wants the kid
what if it's the other way around and
the man wants the kid and the woman
doesn't want the kid that's what i want
to talk about i think it's wild that the
man has no say at all when whether that
child is born or not like if i've been
in that situation so yeah you've been
yeah it's it's wild like if i want to if
i'm saying i'll take care of that kid
and you're still having an abortion even
and she can do this even when you're
married it's wild it's world
i i think
i mean i don't think abortion should be
legal right if it was up to me that
would be a legal procedure
what do you guys think do you think men
should have a say in abortion
yeah because it's their is their child
being born as well okay you know i think
it's a joint commitment
in the idle world i would it would be
great to have 50 50
with that but
you were bought like if a guy wants the
baby right
if the guy wants a baby once you were
bought if he's if you two are together
for instance right and you say you know
what i know we're together but i don't
want this child
does he just is he have a right to just
leave you after that
do you think he's just like all right
bye
that's a big thing you know that's a
that's the same as like marriage
if he wants to get married and you
didn't right that at that point in time
and you say like i'm not ready he can
still leave yeah you know i think
because what's he supposed to do like go
to the abortion clinic with you
to kill his child at the same time i do
think women
women have to carry the baby it changes
their body it changes you know the
hormones going in in
in their brain in the blood so i do
think at the end of the day it does come
down to the woman but i definitely think
that's why we need to be so careful when
choosing people we sleep with because it
should be a decision that both of you
make together right although it is in
the woman's body and everything and
ultimately it does come down to her we
need to be careful who we're sleeping
with
so these issues don't arise you know and
talk about it beforehand i think the
question off camera
is a good one because
we're getting to the point now where you
get the conflation between
what men and women can actually do with
their bodies versus what we think is
morally right right so for me you're
talking about that great area the gray
bit that massive grey area that we're
talking about see because the way i see
it is is that what you've just said
there is spot honest your body
so therefore
i'm on the side of if you don't want the
child
then maybe at that point would be the
woman's decision
because she has to go through something
that men can never go through right so
the the the constant pursuit of equality
in society this is where it gets messed
up because we're not equal
we can't we cannot give birth as men so
therefore
if the conversation is the woman wants
to have the child
because you're you're the incubator
but the man doesn't want it that's i
think that is a separate debate versus
the same question in reverse because the
physical
uh
the physicality of actually having a
baby
but but it's not our body
it's the kid's body it's a unique dna
sequence that's unique from the mother
and the fathers it from the moment of
conception i understand that but i was
just answering the
should have the question
so so you think she should have full
control
i didn't say full control but i think if
if there is a case where she doesn't
want to have the child
this is where it gets so great i
actually feel like if she doesn't want
to have the child then she should have
the right to say that she doesn't want
to have the child but if she doesn't you
don't it's a different that's a
different question because we're not men
and women are different
but it's sorry this is what i was
wanting to ask like you know
is
plain
is it her child so is it a body because
you know if she was
let's say the baby was a boy would you
now say she has a dick you know i i
doubt you would because
it's not her body if that makes sense no
but it's her body that's carrying the
baby
we understand what you're getting at but
it's like so for example it's me yeah
i'm carrying the baby so if i don't want
to go for the physical changes i have
the right to say not that i agree with
abortion but you can do that eight
months you can change your mind at eight
months
but is it different why is it different
what makes you different the process and
the the chemicals
in some states in america you're still
allowed to make that decision well here
you're allowed to up to six months which
is good which is crazy because the
earliest baby that's survived from
giving birth is 21 weeks and it's legal
at 24.
so a baby that's survived on its own at
21 weeks and at 24 they can still abort
it
and that's what i'm saying what i'm
saying because at what point does it
stop being oh this is my body my choice
because if the argument is my body my
choice then you should be able to abort
up to nine months exactly which in
certain places in america they were
actually advocating for yeah i mean
there's even places in america i mean a
senator got caught talking about how
um if a woman has an abortion and the
baby survives that they can't give that
baby medical treatment yeah
like a senator got caught and planned
parenthood also got caught selling body
parts of children to research clinics
yes they did
but nobody ever cares about that or
talks about that they don't i got a
solution for this if the woman doesn't
want to have the child then i'll take
the childhood every day
that's what i do with all my children i
said if you don't have the child i'll
take it full time and you don't have to
have anything to do with it that's what
you're gonna do about the nine months
before
the whole nine months that's almost a
year of her life but again
but it's the same argument you make for
men who you have children they don't
want it's like you decide to have sex
one at a time sorry sorry go on
for 18 years i have to look after the
kid
which is why it should be a choice
between the both of you right so what
i'm saying when we're making a choice
we're making a choice of casual sex
we're not making a choice of
having a baby every time not every time
you have casual sex you have the choice
i mean not every time you have casual
sex you want to have a baby right
because you're not a virgin and you
haven't got a child so that means you
you have you're allowed to have the
choice whether or not you're allowed to
have casual sex as a woman as a man we
should be able to have casual sex
without the the chance of you getting
pregnant especially when there's so many
contraceptions for you to like
not get pregnant even after the baby's
been conceived no one's saying for you
to wait six months there's more than off
the pill there's a three day pill
there's there's there's different ways
and i'm saying this to say
we if we had more of a choice maybe it
would be more fair up okay but
respectfully there are also male
contraceptive yes so if you want to have
casual sex take a male contraceptive um
they're not but they're not readily
available at this point male 1 can also
question about the only the only thing
that's available is a condom but girls
can still steal those the nba is issued
statements to nba players saying to
flush your condoms because women are
we're stealing them but you'll heard
what happened with drake okay go ahead
go ahead can't you reverse a vasectomy
yeah that's a surge i think there's a
difference between a surgical procedure
which can be irreversible
versus birth control morning after pill
which i mean there are side effects from
sure
but i think we can agree a vasectomy is
like one step further yeah but if
if you want to be having casual sex like
that and you really don't want to
get someone pregnant you're not taking
those precautions beforehand before
sleeping with someone then shouldn't you
do that that's my point but that's the
point the same with the women like
shouldn't you do that shouldn't you
think about that before you get an
abortion
so that's why i'm saying like they
shouldn't have a bailout because they
made their bed lie in it are you
advocating for men to have vasectomies
so are you saying no no
no i'm saying if you want to sleep
around and not deal with any of the
consequences like if you're not taking
the time to find out who the woman is
before like if she will listen to your
point of view if you can have a
conversation about it etc then go have a
vasectomy and sleep with whoever you
want you don't have to deal with any of
those consequences you know yeah would
you sorry yeah i was going to say the
same thing for you do you see how do you
see it do you see the double standards
right so for you for you it's my body i
could choose what i want and for me you
should have you should have you should
have took precautions it's your problem
if you have it so now i'm saying to you
if it was it was switched around to you
now and say okay we have casual sex but
abortion is not allowed you have to have
you have to have um the kid you would
soon see how many women not have kids
because they're not going to jump on now
because it's because